inzwischen gehen viele forscher
tatsächlich davon aus dass die nächste
große pandemie aus der massentierhaltung
kommen wir schalten wir live nach
sustrum im emsland zu matthias matschke
betreiber einer großen
schweinemastanlage herr matschie muss
das denn sein mit dem ganzen antibiotika
für tiere ja schön ist das nicht auch
für uns land würde
wir kommen ja ständig in kontakt mit den
verwandten fächern alte bauernregeln
nächste sau den bauern ankommt schon
bald der sensenmann sobald einer polin
kollegen hier in folge brüssel hat
kriegen alle 30.000 tiere antibiotika so
einfach mal zwischendurch als leckerli
ja weil die so eng zusammenstehen weiß
auch nicht warum die das machen ja aber
deswegen haben wir das problem doch in
deutschland werden sogar
reserveantibiotika also die letzten im
ernstfall noch menschen retten können an
schweine verfüttert nur damit unser
fleisch preiswert bleibt alte
bauernregel solibro ist schön billig
sein schmeckt sie halt auch mal nach
kleine betriebe sind denn da das problem
die forscher fanden multiresistente
keime in 85 prozent der untersuchten
schweinemast und milchviehbetriebe im
grundsatz her können resistente keime
vom tier auf den menschen aber auch vom
menschen auf tiere übertragen werden
wo also der südserbischen sehr
theoretisch so nach kunst den schweinen
normalerweise gar nicht betrifft ja nur
ganz wenige berufsgruppen ja die ganzen
besucher zum beispiel der aus ist im
prinzip egal vorwissen sehen man kann
sie aber diese poppig wie jetzt
stimulieren das ist ja immer noch drauf
springt oder ich selbstvertrauen
gesammelt
ja
ist ein interessantes detail herr
matschke ich hatte jetzt naiverweise
mehr an die konsumenten gedacht und der
konsument ist und die nächste sau von
allen jeder deutsche frist über den 36
kilo schweinefleisch pro jahr jeder und
da sind die bekloppten wie gerne schon
mit eingerechnet
ich kenne leute die essen freiwillig
mettbrötchen hohes schwein dann könnte
ich genauso gut vorzug schmerzen hast du
bessere überlebenschancen können das
nicht so machen wir die denn in dänemark
sind wenigstens reserveantibiotika für
tiere verboten ne wollte unser
bisheriger landwirtschaftsminister
schmidt nicht der ist grundsätzlich
gegen verbieten alle bauernregeln
kritisch mit es schwer auf rath denn
trinken glyphosat
naja immerhin müssen wir sagen sind
antibiotika seit ein paar jahren als
mast beschleuniger verboten
offiziell in geringer dosis machen wir
es natürlich weiter wachsen die wista
sind der hammer
jetzt ist sie schon wieder aus ihrer box
abgehauen matthias
[Applaus]